your sources say a Jew and a Christian
will take the punishment for you your
sins for you cuz you said you believe a
human takes your sins for you so we're
going to show you that you believe the
same thing we're your savior we're your
savior we're your savior we your saviors
bro come on
man okay listen y y'all like some Hadith
freaks y'all need to calm down stop love
the
sunna Muslim 2 2767 a Abu mus reported
Allah's messenger saying somebody say
Allah this what Allah's messenger says
no bro it's all good talk to you the day
of Resurrection Allah will deliver to
every Muslim a Jew or a Christian and
say that is your rescue from Hellfire I
mean I'm not I'm not no like I'm not
like I'm not going to put my faith in a
statue and I'm not going to put it in a
human bro I know God is but Muhammad is
putting it in a human how when he said
says that the Jew and the Christian is
your rescue from Hellfire you need to
put your faith in us bro we're your
rescue we're your saviors from Hellfire
here's the topic hello what up what up
what's going on nothing much how are you
man I'm doing good bro I'm not gonna lie
look from my point of view bro I'm not
gonna lie you just like you just human
worshiping When You Believe In Jesus as
God why you say that because he's a
human he's a human yes and he died just
like how me supposedly to y'all he died
can a can a human say things like I give
eternal life to the Sheep Maybe by
guiding them to the true path which is
to the one true God by telling them to
follow the true path of God but who's
the one who gives eternal life God so if
he's saying that he's the one who gives
eternal life who's he saying he is he
can't really be saying that bro like
you're saying what Paul wrote years ago
after he died and he didn't even like
Jesus bro you're not answer the question
if he how is he gonna give eternal life
when he died if he's saying that he's
the one who gives eternal life who is he
claiming to be okay so why is he always
referring to the father not answering
the question bro okay he's not he's he
can't be God so why is he always
referring to the father so then if he's
not God then when he says he's prob
referring to the father who gives
eternal life I'm the one who gives
eternal life you said only God gives
eternal life so so the father that he's
always referring to is not does etal
life on a second who is Jesus claiming
to be when he says he gives eternal life
a prophet so a prophet can give eternal
life I mean if if he if he's if you
follow his message by going to the one
true God yes wait just to be clear
you're saying and I want you to be clear
that a prophet can give eternal life yes
through the message that he comes with
if you believe in one true God don't
take what I'm saying out of subject you
know I'm not saying that the actual
Prophet can do it hold don't what I'm
saying though hold on so why is he
refering to the hold on I know you don't
drop me why is he why would I drop you
you just we're celebrating so why is he
always referring to the father answer my
question just pause we're gonna answer
your questions okay okay go ahead can I
get a second to celebrate this momentous
occasion matter of fact Brothers can you
guys help me celebrate this my brothers
in my OG my original Quan only
Christians can you guys celebrate the
new brother who just left Islam can you
guys come up and celebrate with me no
hold on time out so
if you follow the message
of listen bro you being childish bro
relax calm down you being childish real
talk yes come on guys come up and
celebrate but you being childish bro we
got somebody else who just left this
line if you follow the message of the
Prophet you can't get congratulations J
abbar bro it's not Yeshua Isa calm
Yeshua come on let's celebrate the
brother yes
Al yes
alhamdu
yesu Hallelujah hey Bro Look bro free
Palestine it's one true God bro we all
suppos to follow the message of
believing in one true God yeah I don't
know what y'all got going on about
brother that is such a blessing Jes
know all of Heaven is rejoicing right
now salvation
so they are
so bless you God bless you bro
like yeah you know that he mentioned
something about the straight path what
he said he he he said he said that you
have to be the straight path to be
God on a straight path but Jesus said
that he is the path thean the path to
the path to basically taking all of your
sin right and you get to do whatever you
want and it seems like you found it so
so congratulations on leaving Islam
right now you just need to find Christ
never it don't work like that BR yesu
abbar
yes Yeshua all right I got to get back
to work God bless you
guys brother Dan thank you guys for
coming up and celebrating this brother
left Islam now we're going to try to
give him the
gospel now I'm not to leave you going
keep being childish bro I ain't lie know
trying to get your live going and all of
that you got some people in here that's
cool to get my live going bro there's a
thousand people in here man did you
realize what he said did you realize
what he said though he said oh you
believe a human can come and take your
sins bro the Jews and the Christian take
your sins for you take the no no
no do not speak on the Jews because they
don't
even your sources say one Jew right now
who's going to agree with
you not one of them is going to agree
with you actually they're not even
believe in Jesus how about we bring up
Muhammad how about we bring up bring up
your sources can we bring no no no you
said bring up a Jew bring up one Jew I
said your sources your sources say a Jew
and a Christian will take the punishment
for you your sins for you because you
said you believe a human takes your sins
for you so we're going to show you that
you believe the same thing we're your
savior we're your savior we're your
saviors we're your saviors bro come on
man okay listen y y'all like some Hadith
freak y'all need to calm down stop
taking words out need tox we love Thea
don't because it's some crazy things
it's not even y' don't I don't know if y
got hadiths and Y religion but in your
Bible itself says some crazy stuff no no
no we we we love the sunna of muham we
love the sunna man we love the soona of
the Prophet let me let me show you what
the you ha muhamad so much allow I can't
hate the pro I can't hate Jesus I can't
hate any Prophet that's what I don't
know why y'all keep saying the word hate
I don't hate any of them they all taught
me about the one true God that's the
same message we all supposed to have I'm
pretty sure when you're in your time of
Calamity you're not thinking of some
human to come save you I'm pretty sure
you're thinking of like a higher power
repat me repeat after
me you sound Arab yourself I'm leane I'm
not I'm not Arab bro how are you lean
you say
say repeat after me maybe this will help
him maybe this you're not you're not
Muslim Muslim 2
27678 Abu mus reported Allah messenger
saying somebody say no bro I need you to
just use common
sense I'm trying to show you something
bro this what Allah's messages says nah
bro it's all good it's good to talk to
you the day of Resurrection
Allah will deliver to every Muslim a Jew
or a Christian and say that is your
rescue from Hellfire yeah yeah i' seen
that I've seen that before bro I've seen
that I mean I'm not I'm not no like I'm
not like a person of like crazy
knowledge to really explain everything
to you bro but I'm not going to put my
faith in a statute and I'm not going to
put it in a human bro I know God is
Muhammad is putting it in a human how
when he says that the Jew and the CHR is
your rescue from Hellfire you need to
put your faith in us bro we're your
rescue we're your saviors from Hellfire
you need us okay bro I'm not I'm not
gonna really talk about something I
really don't
know I'm not I never read that but we
want to show you we make a like where
Gog and Magog will also be like you know
a kind of replacement for I I don't know
too bro I don't know so let me give you
this one true God bro that's my message
let me give you some props let me give
you some props on a serious note it does
seem I'm serious all seriousness all
right it does seem that you do have a
level of humility because you're you're
open to say hey man I i't seen that I
don't want to speak on something I don't
know that's a good sign that you do have
a level of humility to you so maybe I
can have a conversation with you however
I need you to be consistent you're going
to bring accusations against Christians
saying that our our religion is false
because we believe and I put our faith
in a human for our Salvation then you
have to say that Islam is also false
because Muhammad says that it's humans
that's going to be your salvation you
know what I'm saying so either you got
to be fair and say that Islam is false
too then or say that okay your argument
against us is actually not valid do you
get what I'm saying I understand I
understand clear what you're saying and
I and I completely understand but as far
as the only thing I'm believing that
comes from a human is the prophet
telling me about one true God bro I I I
can't really believe a three in one I
can't believe in a statue I don't know
it's just my Common Sense he just
doesn't allow me to do that okay so what
when you say your common sense so I
don't think human gonna go I'm appeal to
your common sense so you're telling me
that God fits into your common
sense yes so God is not above your
common sense he fits right into your
common sense no no no okay he does I
can't really I don't understand God no
of course some things in life that I
mean I I question you know you know so
if God were to reveal some things about
himself that do not fit into your common
sense is that reason to reject him no
all right so just because my friend you
have a particular concept of God that
you feels fits your common sense while
we have a concept of God that doesn't
fit your common sense it doesn't mean
that our concept of God is false but I
but I agree but I agree with the part
about you know Jesus and everything like
that you know I do believe that he came
I do believe that he told us about you
know God and everything like that so
it's kind of hard to not believe it's
just I feel like things kind of went
wrong you know and people got misled the
have
idea one
that things went wrong you would have to
have an idea of what the right path was
so when you're telling me that people
straight away from what Jesus used to
teach means that you know what Jesus
used to teach so where do you get the
teachings of Jesus where can I find that
I mean the teachings of Jesus is like
the same laws that were given to Moses
they were just also given to Jesus and
now we still have them today you know
like you know so if somebody I got you
if somebody taught that Jesus came
changing the laws of Moses would they be
a false teacher no because I believe
some things that was revealed to Moses
and Jesus they weren't really forbidden
at that time like you just said dude you
said that Jesus came with the same laws
of Moses but now you're saying that well
actually he did yeah yeah but I'm saying
as far as
today Jesus back then they could drink
and stuff now you can't drink no more
I'm talking about Jesus not today Jesus
I I don't know the Torah is not
preserved theil is not preserved so then
how do you know that Jesus came with the
same laws Moses had from the Quran the
Quran the Quran where does the Quran
tell you that it says that Moses and he
Moses Abraham and he they all had the
same scripture no no it doesn't it tells
you that they had different scriptures
in fact it tells you that Jesus came and
changed some of the laws of Moses teach
them Shake teach him Shake Abraham and
Moses had the same scripture it was
Abraham and Moses
okay Thena came with the so he no show
me in the Quran where it says that
Abraham had the Torah okay hold on give
me one second that's crazy didn't even
want me to finish that's wild man that's
wild man it's crazy man oh hey man I
appreciate everybody that was on YouTube
all 1500 of y'all and all the you know
950 of y'all here that was saying that
was celebrating our new friend
for leaving Islam the way he did by
saying prophets can give eternal life he
committed Sherk the unforgivable sin and
now he is a disbeliever According to
Islamic standards and is no longer in
Islam Man One Step Closer Guys One Step
Closer
wowow hey can you hear me yes I can hear
you now when you're paused we can hear
hey look uh hey look uh read chapter 2
verse uh 136 what does it say did you
just read it yeah I just read it but I
can't read it while like I'm uh okay
yeah I got you I'll get it I'll get it
I'll get it I'm not on the computer I
got you I got you C I got you don't but
look bro I a even hold you up bro like
for real you know I'm saying you you
know I'm saying skip whatever it's all
good bro uh that's all I'm not skip you
I'm having a good conversation with you
I'm not gonna skip you I feel like I
feel like we we getting somewhere you
left Islam earlier now we're you know
just talking about some stuff getting
some more knowledge all right it was uh
136 you said uh
chapter 2 verse 136 vers 136 say we
believe in Allah and that which that
which has been sent down to us and that
which has been sent down to Abraham
ishma Isaac Jacob and to asbat and that
which H has been given to Moses and Issa
and that which has been given to the
prophets from their lord we make no
distinction between any of them and to
him we have submitted yeah that's I got
that from all right where does it say
that Abraham had the same scripture of
Moses it say it seems like they were
given two different things okay hold on
let me Let Me Rad it again give me one
second we believe in that which has been
sent down to us and that which has been
sent down to Abraham and to ishma and to
Isaac and to Jacob and that which has
been given to Moses so it's different
from what you're reading is it all the
same like I'm not understand like
different bro they've all been given
something they just believe in it all
they believe in all the things that God
has given the prophets doesn't mean that
they were all given the same thing so
the law so basically the rules of
whatever was forbidden got switched on
them uh depending on their time maybe
depending on the law this
okay but look okay so basically then it
just switched up as far as like what was
forbidden and what you can and can't do
so it was all basically believe in one
God though so I mean I don't know but
what see but here's the question what
did these prophets teach about the one
God and how do we know how do we check I
mean I don't know maybe it's because
certain people back then lived like
completely wrong they were doing like
nasty killings and I don't know raping
who know I don't know that's that's not
that's not that's not certain
Revelations came down the CR of the
question listen to the question I asked
what did the prophets like Abraham or
Moses what did they teach about the one
God what did they teach and how do you
know how do you verify it as far as for
me it's only the Quran but the Quran
tells you it's not just the Quran it's
also what they have it's the Torah it's
the gospel it's the Psalms it's the
abrahamic scriptures well yeah I I
believe that would the Torah well I know
I'm not but I know the Torah theil that
was for that people of that time not for
us well so that that's fine and all but
it actually is for the Jews and the
Christians because the Quran tells the
Jews and the Christians even in
Muhammad's time to follow their own
scriptures even when the Quran is there
they have to follow their own scriptures
hey do you believe uh Jesus was a Jew or
Hew but did you just hear what I just
said yeah yeah I heard what you said
yeah I heard focus on what I just said
Quran tells the Jews and the Christians
to follow their own scriptures even in
Muhammad's time even when the Quran was
there why is he telling them to follow
corrupted scripture yeah that's true
that was another thing but I believe
back then they were all believing in one
God was the Trinity and stuff back then
around the Trinity was in the gospel and
in the Torah man it's always been there
always but how come it's not there now
you can't find the word Trinity at all
now you can't do you believe in Ted I
know Ted yeah I never heard of that what
kind of Muslim are you understand I'm
not gonna sit here and lie like I
started learning like two years ago
after my dad passed and I've been you
know I've been on it since I've been out
prayers and everything look but I
believe in God's I believe God's
merciful bro and I'll be praying I'll be
fasting my none of that is gonna work
none of that works this this is what God
says when he revealed himself through
the prophets it says that your good
works are as filthy w to me because
you're stained with your sin you sinned
against God you've broken his law and so
you're going to stand in his courtroom
to face his wrath he's not going to just
sweep your sin under the rug man he has
to deal with your sin he can't just say
oh well no you're good that would mean
he's unjust so with you being
disconnected from the message of the
prophets you being disconnected with how
God Reveals His salvation you don't have
it you're going to be in trouble you
thinking that all these prayers and
fasting going to help you it's going to
be for nothing you're not even fasting
or praying towards the right God bro all
right like this what me and you just
like I don't know this is where we
different at bro do you have a Bible n
no get a Bible man the Quran tells you
to get a Bible it says when you don't
know look this chapter 10 verse 94 of
the Quran Surah 10 verse 94 talking to
Muhammad it says if you are in doubt
about what we have revealed to you then
go and ask the people who have been
reading the book look before you that's
chapter 10 ver 94 of the Quran bro so
even the Quran told Muhammad that if
he's in doubt to come to us because we
have the scripture by which the Quran is
supposed to be verified by now what
sense what sense does it make for Allah
to tell Muhammad to come to us if we
don't have the truth what sense does
that make I understand I read I've seen
that before too so then if it's if if it
was good enough it's important enough
for even Muhammad to come to us and see
what you know what God has revealed
through our scriptures even more so do
you who follows Muhammad get a Bible bro
or if you don't get a physical one go
online start reading the gospel read the
Torah see what Moses taught what Abraham
taught what Jesus taught what the rest
of the prophets taught see for yourself
all right for sure look I understand you
know with this type of stuff you always
got to do with an open mind open heart
and everything but look where do you
fall sure that when you look at when you
look into Islam where where is the like
the wall for you like what makes I'll
show you this is the wall for me I don't
fall short anywhere because I'm doing
exactly what the Quran tells us look
this is chapter 5 verse 47 all right of
the Quran it says let the people of the
Gospel judge by what Allah has revealed
there in whoever does not judge by what
Allah has revealed therein then they are
of the wrongdoers so the Quran tells me
as a person who believes in the gospel
to use the gospel as my judge so
whatever doesn't line up with the gospel
I judge it to be false so when I read
the Quran and I read the Quran and I see
how the Quran contradicts the gospel on
who Jesus is it contradicts the gospel
on who the prophets are it contradicts
the gospel on who God is it contradicts
the gospel on how I obtain salvation I
have to throw the Quran out as a false
book and that's uh chapter and verse
what that's chapter 5 5 verse
47 5:46 all right all right look I'm
going to do my part bro I see you on
here I I I I'll talk to you again bro
than welome to join anytime man I'm I'm
I I'll be looking forward to seeing you
all right that's no problem you safe bro
too man take care